toute l'actualité du continent africain
ces tours suite sur france 24 à vis de
vous retrouver bienvenue dans votre
journal de l'afrique
le togo à la rescousse lomé présent
répondent présents à bamako pour régler
son différend avec abidjan celui des 49
militaires ivoiriens détenus au mali cas
accusés d'être des mercenaires
correspondance d'emmanuel sodji
en guinée les auteurs du massacre du 28
septembre 2009 seront ils jugés maintes
fois promis et reporter un procès
pourrait avoir lieu cette année le
colonel doumbouya les pour les blocages
sont logistique
après le malien à 6 me et goïta lundi
l'ivoirien alassane ouattara
ce mardi le chef de la diplomatie
togolaise a rencontré les deux
dirigeants il joue la médiation dans la
crise qui oppose le mali à la côte
d'ivoire bamako détient depuis la
semaine dernière 49 soldats ivoiriens
qu'ils accusent d'être des mercenaires
injuste et faux répond à abidjan qui
affirment que les militaires participer
à des opérations
la minus ma emmanuel sadi et notre
correspondante dans la région
c'est le colonel assimi goïta le
président de la transition malienne qui
a demandé au chef de l'état du togo
faure gnassingbé les jouer les bons
offices dans la crise des 49 militaires
ivoiriens retenus au mali alors pourquoi
si meego ita fait-il appel à fantasy
mais est bien parce que le président du
togo a toujours été du côté des maliens
et il s'est positionné en médiateur
entre ce pays et la cedeao quand les
sanctions ont pénalisé le mali il y
avait régulièrement à lomé des
délégation malienne reçu par le chef de
l'état togolais et le ministre togolais
des affaires étrangères étaient très
présents à bamako et dans sa diplomatie
et des sanctions et bien le togo a
toujours pris l'option d'adoucir la
position de la cedeao alors que la côte
d'ivoire elle représentait la ligne dure
alors au final on l'a vu c'est la
diplomatie togolaise qui l'a emporté
puisque les sanctions économiques et
financières contre le mali ont été
élevés le 3 juillet dernier en tout cas
cette demande du colonel keïta montrent
qu'ils recherchent une solution
diplomatique à cette mini crise le
président togolais qui a déjà engrangé
un succès diplomatique a de sérieuses
chances de faire libérer les 49
militaires maliennes
près de 150 morts plus d'une centaine de
femmes violées c'était
28 septembre 2009 au stade de conakry en
guinée un rassemblement à l'appel de
l'opposition avaient été sévèrement
réprimées par les forces de sécurité
treize ans après le président de
transition plaide pour la tenue d'un
procès plus de 400 parties civiles
doivent y participer problème le
tribunal où il doit se tenir et toujours
en chantier précision de malik diakité
selon dit le ministre de la justice a
rencontré leurs représentants des
victimes pour échanger sur les modalités
et les dispositions de la tenue de ce
procès tant attendu alphonse à l'oreille
tu as tout d'abord exprimé l'engagement
du gouvernement pour la tenue d'un
procès juste juste et équitable il a
aussi sollicité l'accompagnement de tous
pour la réussite de ce procès attendu
depuis 13 ans de leur côté les
représentants des victimes ont fait part
au garde des sceaux de leurs
préoccupations ils ont notamment exigé
la présence de tous les présumés
coupables dont le chef de la junte à
l'époque le capitaine moussa dadis
camara actuellement au burkina faso
selon le ministre de la justice en
toutes les dispositions seront prises
pour la réussite de ce procès nous avons
réactualisé
de nos jours tous les textes arrêté qui
détermine les organes de pilotage
l'organisation de ce procès est la
position du gouvernement de monsieur le
président de la transition
c'est que notre pays
doit désormais s'inscrire dans le
respect des droits de l'homme sous
toutes ses formes des propos qui ont
rassuré les représentants des victimes
nous avons fait nos demandes regardez ce
qui nous a rassurés que pour les ai tous
les accusés dans ce procès comparaîtront
et toutes les dispositions pratiques
vont être prises pour que ce procès soit
une réussite parce que c'est là dessus
l'honneur et la venue de la justice jean
pierre qui sont en jeu et je pense que
le ministre nous a rassurés de ce point
de vue et nous en termes dont la
compagne est effectivement dans la
conduite de cette mission qui nous
l'espérons va
mettre fin à l'impunité de la nôtre pays
pour rappel le 28 septembre 2009 sous la
junte militaire dirigée par moussa dadis
camara un rassemblement à l'appel de
l'opposition au stade de conakry avait
deux repris mais dans le sang par les
forces de sécurité ce massacre avait
fait près de 150 morts et une centaine
de femmes violées selon plusieurs ong le
procès promis par le régime de l'ex
président alpha condé n'a jamais eu lieu
il avait tenté d'entrer en europe de
manière illégale c'était le 24 juin
dernier vial enclaves espagnoles de
melilla en territoire marocain 33
migrants ont des traits condamné par la
justice du maroc à 11 mois de prison
ferme à l'époque près de 2000
clandestins en majorité soudanais vais
essayer de franchir le grillage de
séparation à 23 personnes y ont laissé
leur vie
saison des pluies meurtrière au niger
neuf personnes sont décédées dans les
fortes précipitations qui ont touché le
pays le week-end dernier principalement
les zones du sud frontalière du nigeria
plusieurs milliers d'habitants sont
sinistrées la mauvaise urbanisation de
certaines communes les rend plus
vulnérables
harold girard france 24
plus de 16 mille personnes ont vu leurs
foyers détruits ou partiellement
endommagées les villes les plus touchées
sont celles de zain d'air et de maradi
le gouvernement nigérien a été clair les
citoyens doivent éviter dans les jours à
venir de passer la nuit dans des
habitations dites trop fragile un
conseil quasiment impossible à respecter
pour la plupart des riverains beaucoup
accusent les autorités nigériennes
d'avoir fait preuve d'un manque de
prévoyance quant à ces catastrophes
depuis plusieurs années déjà une restons
toujours dans un urbanisme de rattrapage
d après installation pour avoir les
problèmes qu'on va essayer de résoudre
le problème or on m 30 ans au pouvoir
faire tout cela parce qu'il faut
réhabiliter encore les centres villes
pour les villes qui ne sont pas riches
mais également à faire participer et les
populations
politique de développement des villes
les communes les maires de l'or va
rester dans leurs bureaux seulement en
train d'imaginer
les maires doivent associer la
population qui connaissent bien leur
milieu et voir quelles sont les
solutions alternatives pour pouvoir
avoir un cadre de vie décent la capitale
niamey est encore épargnés par la
catastrophe qui touche plusieurs villes
du sud du pays et pourtant plusieurs
zones de la ville reste menacé par des
épisodes pluvieux encore à venir
particulièrement celles aux abords du
fleuve niger
régulièrement sinistrées par les crues
c'est un ingrédient essentiel dans
l'alimentation tunisie le blé plus de la
moitié provient du cren compte tenu de
la guerre la serre elle la céréale vient
à manquer les prix flambent
résultat le pays se tournent vers l'auto
production mais la crise financière et
politique complique la donne reportage
france 24 signale il ya blaise et âme
dit l'élu
dans cette minoterie de la capitale ces
machines transforme des tonnes de blé en
farine et semoule au quotidien ici nous
sommes au besoin à l'emballage la farine
avoir onze
m
l'industriel 2
patsouris nous fournissons à peu près
500 mort j'y passerais sont de marché
local avec l'impact de la guerre en
ukraine sur l'importation de blé tendre
qui sert à la farine les minotiers
insiste sur la valorisation du blé dur
en partie produit localement le blé dur
et les consommer à la fois pour
l'industrie des pâtes pour les ménages
aussi et pour les artisans de
volant j'ai aussi pour faire des dupes a
donc
il présente un grand substitut pour la
farine
surtout dans les zones rurales chez nous
on semble beaucoup plus le pain de se
moque de pain de farine pour améliorer
son autosuffisance emblée la tunisie
aimerait doubler sa production au blé
dur d'ici 2023 mais encore faut-il que
le secteur agricole puis suivent cet
agriculteur est en pleine moisson
bat cette récolte est en demi-teinte
elle est ici vous on est devant un champ
qui est plutôt beau et il ya des régions
où il ya quasiment rien par exemple sur
des régions comme à goran qui sont des
régions céréalières traditionnellement
le sud du kef et où nos collègues
pâtissent des effets de la sécheresse
mais aussi de défaut de distribution des
semences et des engrais azotés notamment
attend beaucoup d'agriculteurs
délaissent les cultures céréalières pour
ces raisons donc revenir à faire de
doubler et le faire bien il faut le
faire avec des agriculteurs et donc il
faut les bonifier sur tous les plans
crédit pris appui
faute de réformes la dépendance à
l'importation un coup surtout en période
de crise économique le pays doit
emprunter près de 500 millions de
dollars aux bailleurs de fonds pour
assurer son stock de céréales cette
année
du café pour redonner un coup de fouet à
la forêt tropicale du mozambique
l'initiative revient à des agronomes le
monde grandiose à est en pleine
renaissance un projet également
générateur d'emplois charles ici devant
le café ne réveillait pas que les hommes
ces plans semblent ramener à la vie
cette forêt tropicale au coeur du
mozambique pendant des décennies des
combattants étaient retranchés dans
cette réserve de go wrong osa ils
abattaient des arbres pour faire pousser
leurs cultures de subsistance sans
forcément réaliser qu'ils assécher la
terre il faut des ses choix chez nous
avant la situation politique ici était
très difficile situation
ne pouvait pas travailler parce que les
combattants du frélimo et de la renamo
s'affronter ici libre depuis la fin du
conflit il y a trois ans des agronomes
ont trouvé un moyen pour faire repousser
les arbres tout en créant de la richesse
ils ont importé la culture du café du
zimbabwe et puisque ces plans ont besoin
d'ombré les habitants plante des arbres
tout autour
transports où nous incitons les
communautés à participer à la
reforestation en leur fournissant un
revenu additionnel
nous créons ce revenu grâce au café mais
aussi en cultivant des variétés locales
entre les plans comme les bananes ou les
poids
des cultures est essentielle alors que
les prix des aliments de base grimpe
notamment en raison de la guerre en
ukraine le café lui est exportée avec
grand succès ce qui rapporte des revenus
bienvenue aux habitants de la région
voilà pour ce journal de l'afrique a
retrouvé évidemment sur notre site
internet france 24 points comme merci de
votre fidélité merci également à khalid
aussi ce soir qui officiait en régie une
première réussie merci reste avec nous
[Musique]